For generations, living happily ever after usually meant getting married. If you found your perfect match and tied the knot, you would be happier, healthier, and less lonely. Meanwhile, single people are often stereotyped as being isolated, self-centered, and unhappy. In this episode, we speak with one psychologist who has dug deep into the research on singles and married couples and finds that everything you think you know about single people is probably wrong. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology. Bella DiPaolo is a project scientist at the University of California, Santa Barbara, and has been described by Atlantic Magazine as America's foremost thinker and writer on the single experience.
长期以来，幸福美满的生活通常意味着结婚。如果你找到了完美伴侣并步入婚姻殿堂，你会更快乐、更健康，也更不孤单。与此同时，单身人士往往被刻板印象化为孤立、自私和不快乐。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位深入研究单身和已婚夫妇的心理学家，她发现你对单身人士的固有看法可能全都是错的。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学话语》。贝拉·德保罗是加利福尼亚大学圣巴巴拉分校的项目科学家，被《大西洋月刊》誉为美国关于单身体验最重要的思想家和作家。
She has written more than 100 academic publications, including many on the topic of single life, and is the author of the book Singled Out, How Singles Are Stereotyped, Stigmatized, and Ignored, and Still Live Happily Ever After. Her research has been funded by the National Science Foundation and the National Institutes of Mental Health. Welcome, Dr. DePaulo. Thank you so much for having me. There has been a lot of research and media coverage focusing lately on happiness. You know, one of the big questions seems to be, well, getting married make you happier. We all know, you know, there are unhappy marriages out there, of course.
她撰写了100多篇学术出版物，其中许多关于单身生活的主题，并且是《单身：单身者如何被刻板对待、污 stigma 和忽视，却依然幸福美满》一书的作者。她的研究获得了美国国家科学基金会和国家精神卫生研究所的资助。欢迎您，德保罗博士。非常感谢邀请我。最近有很多关于幸福的研究和媒体报道。你知道，其中一个重大问题似乎是，结婚真的能让你更快乐吗。我们都知道，当然，世界上存在着不幸福的婚姻。
But yet our culture obviously seems to favor marriage over being single. What does the research show us? Do you have to be married to be happy? You are so right about the culture favoring marriage, and you would think with all this celebration of marriage and coupling and weddings, that married people would be happier. But it turns out that if you follow the same people over the course of their lives and ask them over and over again,
然而我们的文化显然更倾向于结婚而非单身。研究向我们展示了什么？你必须结婚才能快乐吗？你说的太对了，文化确实偏爱婚姻，而且你会认为，随着对婚姻、结合和婚礼的种种庆祝，已婚人士应该会更快乐。但事实证明，如果你在人们的一生中追踪同一群人，并一遍又一遍地询问他们，
are you happy, are you happy, are you happy, how happy are you? It turns out that when people get married, they end up no happier than they. they were when they were single. So if they were a really happy single person, they'll probably be a happy married person. If they were not so happy as a single person, they probably will be not so happy as a married person. The only little hint you get that getting married makes you happier is when you first get married, you know, right around the time of the wedding, it's all very exciting. You're a newlywed, right? Yeah, exactly. So sometimes people get a little bump in happiness then, but then they go back to being as happy or as unhappy as they were when they
你快乐吗，你快乐吗，你快乐吗，你有多快乐？事实证明，当人们结婚时，他们的幸福感并不比他们单身时更高。所以，如果他们以前是一个非常快乐的单身人士，他们很可能也会成为一个快乐的已婚人士。如果他们作为一个单身人士并不那么快乐，那么作为已婚人士他们大概也不会那么快乐。关于结婚能让你更快乐的唯一一点迹象，出现在你刚结婚的时候，你知道的，就在婚礼前后，这一切都非常令人兴奋。你是新婚夫妇，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以有时候人们的幸福感会在那时稍有提升，但随后他们又会恢复到单身时的状态，无论他们有多快乐或多不快乐。
were single. And here's something else about that newlywed affect that little increase in happiness around the wedding. It only happens for the married people who get married and stay married. If you're one of those married couples who's going to end up divorced, but as your wedding is approaching, you're already getting a tiny bit less happy. Interesting. Yes. So you're single. Your biography on your website says, I'm single, always have been, always will be. Exactly. What made you want to focus on studying the lives of single people? You know, how much of your research is about understanding yourself? Well, yeah, I have always been single. And I was never insecure about my own desire to live single.
关于那个新婚效应——也就是婚礼前后幸福感的小幅提升，还有一点需要说明。它只发生在那些结婚并保持婚姻的已婚人士身上。如果你是那种最终会离婚的已婚夫妇，那么随着婚礼的临近，你的幸福感其实已经在一点点减少了。有趣。是的。所以你是单身。你网站上的个人简介写着：“我单身，过去一直是，将来也永远是。”完全正确。是什么让你想要专注于研究单身人士的生活？你知道的，你的研究有多少是为了了解你自己？嗯，是的，我一直都是单身。而且我从来没有对单身生活的渴望感到不安全感。
It just felt right to me. Was I really that different in wanting to stay single and feeling like I got a lot out of my single life. And so a lot of my research was motivated by that. In fact, at the very beginning, before I had ever done a single study, I just started approaching other single people at social events. And I'd go up to them and I'd say something like, do you ever feel like you treat it differently because you're single? And the first person I approached had all these stories, and then somebody else joined us, and he had stories, and then somebody else joined us, and we talked all night.
这对我来说感觉很自然。我想要保持单身并且觉得单身生活让我收获颇丰，我真的有那么与众不同吗？因此，我的许多研究都是出于这种动机。事实上，在最初，在我做任何单身研究之前，我只是开始在社交活动中接近其他单身人士。我会走到他们面前，说一些诸如“你有没有觉得因为单身而受到不同的对待？”这样的话。我接触的第一个人讲了所有这些故事，然后另一个人加入了我们，他也有故事，接着又有人加入了，我们聊了一整夜。
There was something about the lives of single people that was really important to them and was not being addressed in the culture at large, in the popular media, and as I would later learn, really not so much by social scientists either. One of the things I did in the last couple of months was to look at psych info, which is the database of all the articles, books, dissertations, etc., that had ever been published relevant to psychology.
单身人士的生活中有些东西对他们来说非常重要，但在主流文化、大众媒体中却未得到探讨，正如我后来了解到的那样，社会科学家们其实也没有过多关注。过去几个月里我做的事情之一，就是查阅心理学文摘（Psych Info），这是一个收录了所有曾经发表过的与心理学相关的文章、书籍、学位论文等内容的数据库。
And I looked for articles on marriage and married people, and I looked for articles on people who had always been single. And I found that just since the year 2000, there have been more than 19,000 articles about marriage and married people. And only 501 about single people. And most of those articles about lifelong single people were just articles in which they were the comparison group in studies where marriage researchers were trying to say, oh, if you get married, you'll be happy or healthier, which, of course, turns out not to be true. So I thought that was really interesting, too.
我查找了关于婚姻和已婚人士的文章，也查找了关于一直单身的人的文章。我发现，仅仅自2000年以来，就有超过1.9万篇关于婚姻和已婚人士的文章。而关于单身人士的文章只有501篇。并且，其中大多数关于终身单身人士的文章只是将他们作为研究中的对照组，婚姻研究人员试图借此证明，哦，如果你结婚了，你就会更快乐或更健康，而这当然被证明是不真实的。所以我认为这也非常有趣。
And it shows that even now, nearly two decades after I first started studying single life, we still are the neglected population among social science researchers. Research is still overwhelmingly about marriage and married people. people. And that is so inappropriate at a time when the number of people who are not married in the United States, if you start counting at 16, so 16 and older, the number of people who are
这表明，即使在今天，在我开始研究单身生活将近二十年之后，我们仍然是社会科学研究中被忽视的群体。研究仍然绝大多数集中在婚姻和已婚人士身上。在这样一个时代，美国未婚人口的数量——如果从16岁开始计算，也就是16岁及以上——未婚人口的数量
not married is greater than the number of people who are married. Yeah. The single population is growing. Yes, and it has been for decades. What are some of the key differences in what single people value versus married couples. I'm particularly interested among those who consciously choose to remain single. Right. Right. I like to, I've been trying to study people who I call single at heart. Those are people who live their best, most authentic, most meaningful lives by living single. So when you ask people who are single at heart, what they think when they know they're going to have some time alone, coming up. Overwhelmingly, more than 95% say they look forward to it, they really savor their solitude, and they don't worry, or they very rarely worry that if they have time to
超过了已婚人口的数量，这种偏爱是极其不合时宜的。是的。单身人口正在增长。是的，几十年来一直如此。单身人士所看重的价值与已婚夫妇有什么主要区别？我特别对那些有意识地选择保持单身的人感兴趣。没错。没错。我喜欢，我一直在试图研究那些我称之为“发自内心的单身”的人。这些人通过单身生活过着他们最好、最真实、最有意义的生活。因此，当你问那些发自内心地单身的人，当他们知道自己即将有一些独处时间时会想什么。绝大多数，超过95%的人表示他们很期待，他们非常享受独处，而且他们不担心，或者很少担心如果他们有时间
themselves, they're going to feel lonely. And yet, social science researchers have been just totally preoccupied with studies of loneliness. Now, loneliness is a really important thing to study. And yet, we also need to be more aware of what people can get out of solitude rather than just worrying about people who are going to be lonely. So that's one of the ways that single people differ from married. They really love their solitude. Another thing is that they really want their work to be meaningful. So there was the study that followed people starting when they were high school, years until they were 27 years old. And when they were 27 years old, the people who had been single the whole time said that they wanted jobs that were meaningful. And the married people
独处，他们会感到孤独。然而，社会科学研究却一直全神贯注于对孤独的研究。现在，孤独是一个非常值得研究的重要课题。然而，我们也需要更多地了解人们能从独处中获得什么，而不仅仅是担心那些会感到孤独的人。所以这是单身人士与已婚人士不同的地方之一。他们真的很享受独处。另一件事是，他们非常希望自己的工作是有意义的。曾有一项研究追踪了一群人，从他们高中时期一直到27岁。当他们27岁时，那些一直保持单身的人表示，他们想要有意义的工作。而已婚人士
were more likely to say they wanted jobs with good pay and good chance to get a raise. Now, you might think, well, the married people just said that because they're married. But if you look back to when they were all in high school and no one was married, then they're married, then they The people who would eventually stay single were already saying that they wanted work that was intrinsically rewarding. And the people who would eventually get married were already saying, I want work that pays well and there's lots of chances to advance. Right. We talked a little bit about the growing number of single people, and I want to go back to that. So is this simply because people are delaying marriage or people just foregoing it all together?
更有可能说他们想要薪水好、有很好加薪机会的工作。现在，你可能会想，嗯，已婚人士这么说只是因为他们结婚了。但如果你回溯到他们都在读高中、还没有人结婚的时候，那么，最终会保持单身的人当时就已经在说他们想要有内在回报的工作。而最终会结婚的人当时就已经在说，我想要一份薪水高、有大量晋升机会的工作。没错。我们刚才谈到了不断增长的单身人口，我想回到这个话题。那么，这仅仅是因为人们推迟结婚，还是人们干脆完全放弃了结婚？
I'm just curious what this says about our society moving forward. Right. So there is a big difference in when people get married now compared to in the past. So, for example, in 1956, men got married on the average around age 22, about half got married before 22, half got married after. women it was 20. Now those ages are 29 and 27. So half of all men who will eventually get married
我只是好奇这说明了我们社会的未来走向。没错。因此，现在人们结婚的年龄与过去相比有很大不同。例如，在1956年，男性的平均结婚年龄在22岁左右，大约一半人在22岁之前结婚，一半人在之后结婚。女性则是20岁。现在这些年龄分别是29岁和27岁。因此，所有最终会结婚的男性中有一半
are not yet married at age 29. And half of all women who will eventually get married are not yet married at age 27. So that's a huge difference in how we spend our early adult lives. And also, more people are simply stuble. staying single. And when you think about the reasons for it, there is people sometimes want to finish their education first, or they want to get a good job first, and that could be difficult with growing inequality in economics and globalization. It just can be harder for people to find
在29岁时尚未结婚。所有最终会结婚的女性中有一半在27岁时尚未结婚。因此，我们在早期成年生活中度过的方式有着巨大的差异。而且，更多的人干脆选择了单身。当你考虑其中的原因时，有时人们想要先完成学业，或者想要先找到一份好工作，随着经济不平等和全球化的加剧，这可能会很困难。人们可能很难找到
the economic security that they sometimes want to have before they first get married. So there are lots of reasons like that. But the reason that I focus on because it gets so little attention is that for some, maybe many single people, they are single because they want to be, because they're embracing single life, because living single is the way they live their best, most fulfilling, most meaningful life. Another way that that single and married people differ in their values and what they care about is that, you know, married people tend to focus on the one, their spouse, and so their life can be centered around this one person. Well, people who are single, maybe especially people who embrace single life,
他们在初婚前有时想要拥有的经济安全感。所以有很多这样的原因。但我重点关注的原因是因为它受到的关注太少，那就是对一些人来说，也许是许多单身人士，他们单身是因为他们想单身，因为他们拥抱单身生活，因为单身生活是他们过上最好、最充实、最有意义的生活的方式。单身人士和已婚人士在价值观和他们关切的事物上不同的另一个方面是，你知道，已婚人士倾向于关注“那一个”人，即他们的配偶，所以他们的生活可以围绕着这个人展开。而单身的人，也许特别是那些拥抱单身生活的人，
like to create a life around the ones instead of the one. So there is research showing that it's single people who are more connected to friends, to siblings, to their parents, to neighbors, their colleagues. And it's just the opposite of our stereotypes, which say, oh, single people are the loners, who are social isolates. And in fact, it's single people who are knitting society together. and these kinds of studies that follow people from when they're single to when they get married
喜欢围绕着“多个人”而不是“单个人”来创造生活。因此有研究表明，正是单身人士与朋友、兄弟姐妹、父母、邻居和同事的联系更紧密。这与我们的刻板印象完全相反，刻板印象说，哦，单身人士是独行侠，是社会孤立者。事实上，正是单身人士在将社会紧密缝合在一起。而且，这些追踪人们从单身到结婚的研究发现
find that when people get married, they become more insular, even if they don't have kids. They tend to focus more on each other, and the time they used to spend with their friends or the attention they used to pay to their parents or their siblings, that sort of diminishes. whereas single people are still connected to other people in those kinds of ways. So that's another way that single and merry people differ. Another is in the meaningful contributions they make. So single people do a lot of volunteering. Single people also are very much there for people who need help.
当人们结婚时，即使他们没有孩子，他们也会变得更加封闭。他们往往更专注于彼此，过去花在朋友身上的时间或对父母、兄弟姐妹的关注度那种程度会有所减少。而单身人士仍然与其他人保持着这种联系。所以这是单身人士和已婚人士不同的另一个方式。另一个方式是他们做出的有意义的贡献。因此，单身人士做了很多志愿工作。单身人士对于需要帮助的人也总是随叫随到。
So for aging parents in particular, if your parents are getting older, and they're needing help, they are much more likely to get it from their grown kids who are single than from their grown kids who are married. And the same thing is true for other people, whether your parents or someone you're related to or someone you're totally not related to at all.
特别是对于逐渐变老的父母，如果你的父母年龄越来越大，需要帮助，他们从单身成年子女那里得到帮助的可能性要远大于从已婚成年子女那里得到帮助。对于其他人来说也是如此，无论是你的父母、亲戚还是毫无血缘关系的人。
If there's someone you know and care about who has the kind of illness or disability that requires help for a long period of time, three months or more, again, it's single people who step in to provide that help more than married people do. And I think that's really interesting because of the stereotypes of single people as leading lives of unfettered pleasure seeing. But in fact, they tend to do a lot of meaningful work. And one last thing I wanted to say about the differences in single and married people is single people experience more personal growth.
如果你认识并关心的人患有需要长期帮助（三个月或更长时间）的疾病或残疾，同样地，挺身而出提供这种帮助的往往是单身人士，而不是已婚人士。我认为这非常有趣，因为人们对单身人士的刻板印象是他们过着不受约束的寻欢作乐的生活。但事实上，他们往往做了很多有意义的工作。关于单身人士和已婚人士的区别，我最后想说的一点是，单身人士经历了更多的个人成长。
So there was this one study that followed single people, more than 1,000 people who had always been single, and followed them over a five-year period, and also followed more than 3,000 people who had been married during that entire five years. And they asked them questions about personal growth and the single people were more likely to agree with statements such as, for me, life has been a continuous process of learning, change, and growth.
曾有一项研究追踪了单身人士，超过1000名一直单身的成年人，对他们进行了为期五年的追踪，同时还追踪了在整个五年期间一直保持婚姻状态的3000多人。研究人员询问了他们关于个人成长的问题，单身人士更有可能同意这样的说法：对我和我而言，生活是一个不断学习、变化和成长的持续过程。
And statements such as, I think it's important to have new experiences that challenge how you think about yourself and the world. Whereas the people who stayed married over that five-year period were more likely to agree with statements such as I gave up trying to make improvements in my life a long time ago. It sounds like single people and married people could actually learn from each other when it comes to leading a richer life or a better life being in happiness. What kind of advice or words of encouragement for single and married people would you give out there?
以及诸如此类的陈述：我认为拥有挑战你对自我和世界看法的全新体验是很重要的。然而，在这五年中保持婚姻状态的人则更有可能同意这样的说法：我很早就放弃了试图改善生活的努力。听起来单身人士和已婚人士在过上更丰富的生活、更好的生活或获得幸福方面，其实可以互相学习。对于那些可能正在收听节目的单身和已婚人士，你会给出什么样的建议或鼓励的话语？
Who might be listening? Let me start with single people. Sure. Because single people are so often pressured, to think that there's something wrong with them, whether they should be trying to get married or trying to find someone. What I like to say to single people is
让我从单身人士开始吧。当然。因为单身人士经常受到压力，认为他们身上有什么问题，无论是他们应该努力结婚还是努力寻找某人。我想对单身人士说的是
live your single life fully, joyfully, and unapologetically. And even if you're a single person who wishes you weren't single, I say the same thing. Those years that you have single, embrace them, live them fully. do the things you've always wanted to do. Don't think about single life the old-fashioned way,
充分、快乐且毫无歉意地过好你的单身生活。即使你是一个希望自己不单身的单身人士，我也这么说。你拥有的单身岁月，去拥抱它们，充分地生活。去做你一直想做的事。不要以老式的方式看待单身生活，
which is single years of the years when you just mark time until you find the one. Don't do that. And then what I have to say to single people, married people, people in between, people who don't know what they want or what they're going to do, is that we live in wonderful times. This is a time when more so than any other time in history, people, if you have the resources, and granted, not everybody does, but if you have the resources, you can choose the life past that works for you, whether that's single life, married life, something that's sort of in between, or if you want to go in between,
那里的单身岁月只是你在寻找真命天子之前消磨时间的岁月。不要那样做。然后我要对单身人士、已婚人士、处于中间状态的人、不知道自己想要什么或要做什么的人说的是，我们生活在一个美好的时代。这是一个比历史上任何其他时代都更能体现这一点的时代，人们——如果你有资源，当然并非所有人都有，但如果你有资源——你可以选择适合你的人生道路，无论是单身生活、已婚生活、某种介于两者之间的状态，或者如果你想在其中穿梭，
the different possibilities, all of those options are possible. is no one blueprint for the good life. We can all get to choose the life paths that work best for each of us as individuals. Well, Dr. DePaolo, thank you so much for joining us. This has been a pleasure. Thank you. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the topics we discussed or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingof psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Andre Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
各种可能性，所有这些选项都是可能的。没有哪一种是美好生活的标准蓝图。我们都可以选择最适合我们每个个体的人生道路。那么，德保罗博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这是一次非常愉快的交流。谢谢。谢谢收听。如果您想了解更多关于我们讨论主题的信息，或者想收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，代表美国心理学协会向您呈献《心理学话语》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。